[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم فده بسي وفي
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل
اخرى هذه اصوات تاتينا من عاصمه النيجر
اليامي وتح تحديدا من امام السفاره
الفرنسيه التي يواجه سفير باريس فيها عدا
تنازليا لمغادره البلاد ينتهي خلال
ساعه وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه
الليله على واقع المعارك المحتدم بالخرطوم
ولاول مره منذ اندلاع المواجهات البرهان
في بورت سودان يلتقي اعضاء الحكومه ومجلس
السياده ومتي يتحدث عن شكل الدوله المطلوب
في ي مفاوضات مقبله ويقول ان النظام
الفيدرالي هو
[موسيقى]
الانسب عد تنازلي جديد في النيجر ساعات
على انتهاء مهله قاده الانقلاب لمغادره
السفير الفرنسي تعزيزات امنيه امام
القاعده الفرنسيه بن يامي مع مظاهرات
مطالبه بخروج القوات الفرنسيه وباريس
تتمسك بموقفها الرافض ومفوض ايكواس يكشف
للجزيره عن طلب المجموعه لقاء قاده
الانقلاب في دوله
محايده مع ترقب كيف تسلم مقاتلات اف
16 زيلنسكي يطالب وزاره الدفاع بتسريع
تجهيز البنيه التحتيه وموسكو تعلن قصف
مطار ومحطه رادار قرب كيف مسؤوله عن توجيه
الطائرات المقاتله والقوات الاوكرانيه تصد
هجوما تصفه بالمعقد وسط وشمالي البلاد
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا مطالبه منظمه العفو
الدوليه لشركه ميتا المالكه لمنصه فيسبوك
بتقديم تعويضات للروهينجا حيث تتهم
المنظمه فيسبوك بالمساهمه بما وصف بفضائح
شنيعه ارتكبت ضد شعب الروهينجيا في
ميانمار عبر خوارزميات سمحت بوجود خطاب
كراهيه كبير كما ناقشنا تعامل فيسبوك
وخوارزميات مع القضايا والدول بمعايير
موحده لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي هل
تعتقدون ان خوارزميات التي تقيد خطاب
الكراهيه تتعامل بمعايير موحده جاءت
النتيجه على النحو الاتي نحو 16% اجابوا
بنعم بينما قال
84% انهم لا يعتقدون ان الخو وزمي تتعامل
بمعايير موحده في كل
المناطق هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على
الشاشه لقاؤنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد
يوميا ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل
عربيا
ودوليا
[موسيقى]
لاول مره منذ اندلاع المواجهات واصل رئيس
مجلس السياده بالسودان القائد العام للجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان الى مدينه بورت سودان
شرقي البلاد بعد زياره امتدت يومين لمدينه
عطبره في الشمال وقال مصدر حكومي للجزيره
ان البرهان سيعقد اجتماعا مع مجلس الوزراء
الذي اتخذ من بورت سودان مقرا له منذ
اندلاع القتال في منتصف ابريل نيسان
الماضي ولدى وصوله مطار بورت سودان التقى
البرهان نائب رئيس مجلس السياده مالك عقار
الذي كان في استقباله برفقه اعضاء في
المجلس من جانبه قال مكتب حاكم اقليم
دارفور ورئيس حركه تحرير السودان مني اركم
الناوي ان حاكم الاقليم غادر مدينه الفاشر
عاصمه ولايه شمال دارفور الى بورت سودان
بولايه البحر الاحمر اضاف المكتب ان زياره
مناوي تاتي للقاء مسؤولي الحكومه
الاتحاديه والمنظمات الانسانيه والقوى
السياسيه للتباحث بشان اثار الحرب على
مواطني
الاقليم مدينه بورت سودان باتت تشكل مقرا
بديلا للحكومه السودانيه منذ الاسابيع
الاولى لاندلاع المعارك بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم الس سريع كما انتقلت اليه بعض
البعثات الدبلوماسيه والمنظمات الانسانيه
فما اهميه هذه المدينه في الخريطه
السودانيه تبعد قرابه 800 ك عن الخرطوم
وهي ثاني اكبر مدن السودان واكثرها اهميه
اقتصاديه حيث تعد البوابه البحريه الكبرى
للبلاد بمينائي الذي يعد منفذا رئيسيا
لاستيراد السلع الاستراتيجيه وتصدير نفط
دوله جنوب السودان تحول مدينه بورت سودان
الواقعه شمال شرق البلاد والمطل على البحر
الاحمر الى مقر للحكومه السودانيه منذ شهر
ايار مايو الماضي وحتى اللحظه فباستثناء
اشتباكات محدوده جدا سيطرت الحكومه
السودانيه على المدينه الاستراتيجيه منذ
اندلاع المواجهات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع وبعد تامين بورت سودان بشكل كامل
انتقلت اليها بعثات دبلوماسيه دوليه
ومنظمات انسانيه وتحولت الى ملاذ امن
للاجانب الراغبين في مغادره السودان سواء
بحرا عبر ميناء المدينه او جوا عبر المطار
فيها ومع توسع رقعه القتال وتقطع السبل
امام السودانيين شكلت بورت سودان احدى
محطات النزوح الداخلي للفارين من الخرطوم
ومدن
مجاوره هذا ولا تزال المعارك محتدمه في
مدن العاصمه الثلاث وولايات اخرى فقد افاد
مراسلنا بشان اخر التطورات الميدانيه بان
قوات الدعم قصفت بالصواريخ والمدافع مواقع
للجيش وسط وشرقي مدينه ام دورمان وقالت
مصادر للجزيره ان قوات الدعم السريع هاجمت
مقر سلاح المدرعات في الخرطوم كما اندلعت
اشتباكات في احياء العشره وجبره وشجره
وغزه وفي ام درمان بث الجيش السوداني صورا
لمساعد القائد العام وعضو مجلس السياده
ياسر العطا قال انها اخذت اثناء تفقده
اليوم جرح العمليات العسكريه في مستشفى
السلاح الطبي بامدرمان ويدير العطاء
العمليات العسكريه للجيش في امدرمان منذ
بدء المواجهات مع قوات الدعم السريع منتصف
ابريل نيسان
الماضي السلام هذا وقال قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان حميتي ان اي مفاوضات
تهدف للتسويه يجب ان تقوم على البحث عن حل
سياسي شامل ودع حمتي الى ادراج بنود في اي
مفاوضات قادمه بينها اعتماد نظام حكم
فيدرالي وحكومه مدنيه تمثل كل اقاليم
السودان اضافه الى اقرار تاسيس جيش سوداني
جديد بغرض بناء مؤسسه عسكريه واحده تناه
بنفسها عن السياسه كما دعا الى ما سماه
تصفيه الوجود الحزبي والسياسي داخل
الدوله ينضم الينا هنا في الاستديو اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني المختص بالشؤون
العسكريه والامنيه اهلا بك سيد اسامه سيد
اسامه فيما تحتدم المعارك في الخرطوم وام
درمان يصل البرهان الى بورت سودان ليلتقي
بالحكومه دلالات لقائه بالحكومه بدايه ا
منذ بدايه الحرب قابت الاداره المدنيه
لهذه الحرب لانه ا السودان منذ عامين يعني
قياده الجيش هي نفسها قياده الدوله ما في
رئيس وزراء ا ف تعطلت الاداره المدنيه
للحرب بانشغال قاده الجيش ب بالعمليات
العسكريه طيب اللقاء بالاداره المدنيه هل
سيغير شيئا من هذا الواقع خروج البرهان من
القياده العامه يعني حوله الى دور سياسي
اكبر من دوره العسكري فهو بحكم الواقع هو
رئيس مجلس السياده فكان الحكومه قد تحررت
من من القياده العامه واصبحت حره في
الحركه ومحاوله حل حله مشاكل السوداني لا
يعني ذلك بانه يدير الجانب السياسي
والعسكري معا هو قائد الاعلى للجيش ورئيس
مجلس السياده بالتالي تبقى الحكومه على
وضعها الحكومه
الان كانت غائبه لانه الضربه هي في
العاصمه الخرطوم شلت العاصمه شله الدوله
لفتره طويله جدا من الزمان الان تشعر
الحكومه انها كثيرا قد تحررت عادت الكثير
من خدمات الدوله عادت المصارف للعمل عادت
اشياء كثيره لانه كل شيء كان مركزي في
العاصمه الخرطوم الولايات نفسها تعطلت
كثيرا بهذه الضربه داخل الخرطوم الان
الحكومه تحررت من هذه الاشياء سؤال يعني
هل الا يعني ذلك بان كل السلطات تمركزت في
يد البرهان المدنيه منها والعسكريه بخروجه
ووصوله الى بورت سودان اصلا اصلا هي
الدوله الدوله لها اربع سنوات في اشكاليات
حقيقيه اربع سنوات الماضيه الدوله
السودانيه في اشكاليات حقيقيه وصراع على
السلطه مستمر ومنذ عامين ليس هنالك رئيس
وزراء في الدوله اصلا في اشكاليه حقيقيه
سياسيه موجوده خروج البرهان لن يحل هذه
المشكله حل هذه المشكله طويل المدى لابد
من توافر اراده وتصور سياسي يعني حتى
الحرب نفسها لا يمكن حلها الا باراده وصنا
ذلك مع ما قيل عن تفعيل الاداره المدنيه
لا تفعيل الاداره المدنيه التنفيذيه حلول
حلول لاداره الازمه واداره الحرب هذا هو
المطلوب طيب فيما يتعلق بتصريحات حمتي في
هذا التوقيت هل باتت المعارك تراوح مكانها
مما يسمح في ايجاد تسويه ما البرهان وصل
الى بورت سودان هناك حديث عن امكانيه
خروجه وزيارات الى الخارج يتحدث السيد
حمتي عن رؤيه
متكامله كيف نفهم ذلك هو اول شيء يعني
قوات الدعم السريع هذا التقدم ان تنتقل من
مربع القاء القبض
واغتيال وقتل رئيس مجلس السياده وجنرالات
الجيش الى طرح
رؤيه لحل اشكالات السودان هذا من جانب
يعني هذا تقدم الشيء الثاني طبعا كل مواطن
سوداني له الحق في ان يطرح اراء سياسيه
لحل مشكله البلد هذه حقوق دستوريه لكن
حركه الدعم السريع هي حركه عسكريه متمرده
ا ليس لها حركه مطلب ولا حركه سياسيه ولا
يمكنها ان تطرح تصور لحل
رؤيه الاشكال السياسي السوداني وهي تصوب
البندقيه الى يعني رؤوس الشع الشعب
السوداني وترتكب الجرائم ضدهم في كل يوم
الا يعني ذلك بان اي مفاوضات مقبله تحولت
من الحديث عن وقف اطلاق النار وترتيبات
امنيه الى قضايا سياسيه باختصار لو سمحت
طبعا اذا تحولت اذلك ستكون اشكاليه كبيره
المشكله في تصورها هي مشكله تمرد الدعم
السريع على الجيش والدوله السودانيه حل
ذلك يتم بترتيبات امنيه تعيد الدعم السريع
الى وحده القياده والسيطره اي حديث اخر هو
محاوله ذر الرمات في العيون ومحاوله
لتغطيه الهزائم التي يتعرض لها الدعم
السريرا لك سيد اسامه عدروس الاكاديميه
السودانيه المختص بالشؤون العسكريه
والامنيه كنت معنا هنا في
[موسيقى]
الاستديو
تقترب المهله التي حددها قاده المجلس
العسكري لسفير فرنسا سيلفان اتيه لمغادره
النيجر من نهايتها لكن ره محليه قالت ان
السفير الفرنسي لم يغادر وامام تجمع شعبي
قال عضو المجلس العسكري العقيد بشير ادامو
ان شعب النيجر سيجبر السفيره الفرنسيه على
المغادره تستمر معركه كسر العظم بين فرنسا
وقاده الانقلاب في النيجر تحدد وزاره
الخارجيه في الحكومه المنبثقه عن الانقلاب
مهله من 48 ساعه للسفير الفرنسي لمغادره
البلاد ترد فرنسا بالقول ان قاده الانقلاب
لا يملكون سلطه طرد سفيرها او سحب اعتماده
لانه قدمه لسلطه منتخبه هل يستطيع قاده
الانقلاب طرد السفير الفرنسي
بالقوه قال عضو المجلس العسكري العقيد
بشير امادو ان شعب النيجر سيجبر السفير
الفرنسي على المغادره ودعا الى مواصله
التعبئه والنضال حتى مغادره اخر جندي
فرنسي النيجر يدرك قاده الانقلاب انهم لا
يستطيعون استخدام القوه مع فرنسا التي لها
قاعده عسكريه كبيره بن يامي بها 1500 جندي
كثير منهم نقلوا من مالي بعد دعوه من قاده
الانقلاب هناك للمغادره ولذلك يلجؤون الى
قوه الشارع هذه مظاهره اخرى نظمت في احد
ملاعب نيامي يستخدم قاده الانقلاب الشعور
الشعبيه المعاديه لفرنسا حتى الان بفعاليه
هنا لافتات تطالب برحيل القوات الفرنسيه
التي تنعت بالارهابي واعلام روسيا وحتى
اعلام شركه فاغنر هل سيكفي هذا لربح معركه
التحدي مع فرنسا لا يمكن تقديم جواب حاسم
لان قاده الانقلاب لا يواجهون فرنسا وحدها
فهناك المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس التي ترفض الانقلاب وتهدد
بتدخل عسكري لاعاده النظام الدستوري في
النيجر رئيس نيجيريا الرئيس الحالي
لمجموعه اكواس بولا احمد تنبو قال ان
الحرب ليست مثاليه للاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
لمنطقه غرب افريقيا لكن الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيه امر مقدس في مواجهه اكواس
التي يتهمونها بالتواطئ مع فرنسا يعتمد
قاده الانقلاب على بلدان شهدت انقلابات من
قبل هي مالي وبوركينافاسو
وغينيا لكن ميزان القوه العسكريه يميل هنا
لباقي اعضاء اكواس الذين تقودهم نيجيريا
القوه الاقليميه الاكبر في المنطقه يبدو
الصراع هنا بين معسكرين معسكر يرى ان
الانقلابات تصبح ضروره لتخليص دول المنطقه
من مشاكلها وانهاء الهيمنه الفرنسيه
ومعسكر يرى ان السكوت عما حدث في النيجر
سيشجع على انقلابات اخرى ويطيح برؤساء
اخرين في المنطقه وتبدو فرنسا مستعده
للاسوا للدفاع عن نفوذ متاكل في
افريقيا ينضم الينا من امام السفاره
الفرنسيه في نيام مراس الجزيره بابا ولد
حرمه بابا كيف هو الوضع حول السفاره
الفرنسيه وه هنالك اي تحركات تشي بامكانيه
خروج
السفير نعم الامور هادئه في محيط السفارت
حتى الان هناك تعزيز للشرطه لافراد الشرطه
لافراد الدرك النيجري حول هذه السفاره
التي كانت قد تعرضت للاعتداء في بدايات
هذا الانقلاب العسكري وبدايه الازمه
السياسيه التي تعيشها النيجر منذ ال 26 من
الشهر الماضي باستثناء بعض المسيرات التي
يبدو انها تنطلق من داخل السفاره السفاره
الفرنسيه نفسها لترقب الوضع حوله لا شيء
حتى الان مثيرا في محيط هذه السفاره
والامور تبدو هادئه هناك هذه التعزيزات
العسكريه وهناك هذا الترقب مع قرب انتهاء
مهله المهله التي اعطتها خارجيه النيجر في
الحكومه المعينه من قبل العسكر للسفير
الفرنسي بمغادره البلاد
في مع حلول منتصف الليله بعد اقل من ثلاث
ساعات هنا هناك هذه الدعوات التي بدات
تظهر اتباعا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
من قبل المنظمات والجمعيات المدنيه
المسانده لانقلاب العسكري تطالب هذه
المنظمات بضروره قطع جميع الامدادات سواء
تعلق الامر بالوقود او بالغذاء او بالدواء
او بالكهرباء عن كل من السفاره الفرنسيه
وكذلك القواعد العسكريه الفرنسيه المنتشره
في في عموم البلاد واهمها تقع في محيط
المطار العاصمه يايام بالاضافه الى منطقه
ولم الى الشمال من العاصمه النيجيريه
انيام هناك هذه الدعوات ما هو حجم
الاستجابه لها في الايام القادمه في
الساعات القادمه وما هي الاجراءات وهل
ستنساها سلطات العسكريه الحاكمه في البلد
خلف هذه الدعوات الداعيه الى الحصار الى
هذا الحصار الاقتصادي للقواعد العسكريه
الفرنسيه وسفاره الفرنسيه الامور ما تزال
على طبيعتها السفاره حتى الان تتمتع
بالكهرباء وتضيء وان كانت اضاءه باهته كما
هو حال عموم منطقه عموم مدينه نيامي التي
تعيش نقصا حادا في الكهرباء منذ قطع
الجاريه امدادات الكهربائيه عن هذا البلد
ضمن اطار العقوبات التي فرضتها دول
الاكواس على النيجر بابا ولد حرمه مراس
الجزيره من امام السفاره الفرنسيه في
نيام قال السفير عبد الفتاح موسى مفوض
الشؤون السياسيه والسلم والامن في مجموعه
اكواس ان المجموعه لم ترى اي خطوات ملموسه
من المجلس العسكري في النيجر وانها لن
تنتظر الى ما لا نهايه واضاف موسى في نشره
سابقه على الجزيره انهم غير مستعجلين
للجوء الى الخيار العسكري في
النيجر نحن لا نستعجل الخيار العسكري لقد
كانت هناك الكثير من الجهود التي تتعلق
بالوسطه رئيس نيجيريا السابق الجنرال عبد
السلام والسلطان سكوتو كانوا هناك وتحدثوا
كممثلين عن سلطات اكواس وكان هناك وفد من
العلماء اعطوا تقريرهم الى رئيس نيجيريا
وطلب منهم الاستمرار في جهود الوساطه
وبالتالي نحن نعطي الوساطه كل جهد ووقت
ممكن من اجل ان تؤتي ثمارها لكننا في
الوقت نفسه لن ننخرط في مفاوضات بلا
نهايه من جانب اخر اقر موسى بان العقوبات
كان لها تاث كثير على شعب النيجير مشيرا
الى ان ذلك لم يكن هدف اكواس كما قال كما
كشف انه طلب من قاده الانقلاب لقائهم في
بلد محايد والالتقاء فيما سماه منتصف
الطريق واطلاق سراح الرئيس بازوم
كبادرة وهذا لا ترغب فيه اكواس اكواس تهتم
بشعب النيجر واجراءات المجلس العسكري هي
التي اوصلت البلاد الى ما هي عليه هناك
انقطاعات للطاقه الكهربائيه وارتفاع
للاسعار وهذا ليس ما نريده هناك ايضا توتر
داخل البلد وبالتالي فان الوضع الصعب على
المجلس العسكري من اجل تجنيد وحشد الناس
في الشوارع انهم ادركوا ان المجلس العسكري
يقوم بتغذيه المزاج الشعبوي في البلاد
لكنه لا يفكر في مصلحتها اكواس حذرت
المجلس العسكري وطلبت منه ان يقبل بعرض
الوساطه والمفاوضات لرفع العقوبات والتحرك
نحو استعاده النظام الديمقراطي الكره في
ملعبهم العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين الدول
تحكمها اتفاقيه فينا العرض التالي يعرفنا
على ابرز
بنودها اتفاقيه فينا للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه
عام
1961 تحدد العلاقات بين الدول وعمل
البعثات الدبلوماسيه كما تؤطر مفاهيم عده
كالحصان الدبلوماسيه وقطع
العلاقات
191 دوله وقعت على اتفاقيه فينا التي
تتكون من 53 ماده تقول الماده الثانيه ان
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين الدول تنشا كما
توفد البعثات الدبلوماسيه الدائمه بناء
على الاتفاق المتبادل بينها تختص الماده
التاسعه بتوضيح مصطلح شخص غير مرغوب وتقول
انه حق الدوله في اي وقت وبدون ذكر
الاسباب ان تبلغ الدوله الاخرى ان رئيس او
اي عضو من طاقم بعثتها الدبلوماسي اصبح
شخصا غير مرغوب فيه عند قطع العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه بين دولتين فانه يتعين وفقا
للماده
ال5 احترام وحمايه مباني البعثه
الدبلوماسيه ينضم الينا من مدينه مومباس
الكينيه جومبي عمر جومبي الخبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه والمسؤول السابق في الامم
المتحده سيد جومبي المهله التي منحتها
السلطات الانقلابيه للسفير الفرنسي شارفت
على الانتهاء بتقديرك ما الخيارات امام
السلطات الانقلابيه في حال لم يخرج السفير
الفرنسي لم يغا
نعم شكرا على الاستضافه انا اعتقد ان هذا
هذا الامر سوف ينتهي ب مفاوضات سريه يعني
سلفان لن يؤخذ على ناصيته يعني كما يقولون
ان يخرج بالقوه لان فرنسا يعني لوحتى
الذين المجلس العسكري تعرف ثقل فرنسا
و ايضا اي عمل غير مرغوب فيه سوف تؤدي الى
نتائج غير مرغوبه ل بالنسبه للقاده انفسهم
فلذلك انا اعتقد ان هذه الامور ربما
الساعات بقيت قليله ثلاث ساعات من الان
واعتقد ان هناك مفاوضات سريه جاريه الان
على حفظ ماء الوجه بالنسبه لسفير سانتي
وفرنسا وكذلك المجلس
العسكري فالذين يقولون ان المجلس العسكري
سوف يارب هذا التير وي من البلد اظن هذه
مبالغه التهديدات بان الشعب النيجير شعب
النيجير سيجبر السفير الفرنسي على الخروج
ما مدى
واقعيتها كما قلت ان هذا طبعا المجلس
العسكري لابد ان تظهر للناس المؤيدين انه
يعني يقف يعني بقوه ضد فرنسا الدوله التي
يعني هي المجلس ذاته تشك
انه تريد يعني ارجاع الاقارب الوراء طبعا
ربما ارجاع الرئيس المعزول محمد بازون الى
منصبه هذا هذا هو الشرط وعليه فان
المفاوضات ستكون جاريه على ذلك فاذا اتفق
ان الامور يعطى المجلس العسكري
ا والترتيبات الامنيه
واظن اعتقد ان ا الشعب المجلس العسكري
لن لن لن تترك الشعب يعني
عمل مفوض الشؤون السياسيه والسلم والامن
في مجموعه اكواس قال للجزيره ان المفاوضات
لن تستمر الى ما لا نهايه كيف تقيمون ما
وصل اليه هذه المفاوضات الى حد
الان
طبعا هذه
المفاوضات انا اعتقد
ان
الايكوس عمل عمل يعني خطا ضريع في اعطاء
مهله في في في يعني هي بالفعل رفض مطالب
المجلس العسكري على ان
سوف تعد للانتقال الى الى الطه الوطنيه في
غضون ثلاث ثلاث سنوات هذا كان كان مبدا
جيد جدا للمناقشه والتفاوض عليها واما
الان
فالامور متعقده جدا اعرف ان المجلس
العسكري يعني تكوى على نارين النار في
الداخل والنار في الخارج هو يريد ان ان
يظهر للناس انه يعني انقلابي وثوري وان
سيغير الامور في داخل البلد فلا يستطيع ان
يقبل بكل الاطروحات بدون النظر الى وضعه
نعم جنبه عمر جمبي خبير في الشؤون
الافريقيه ومسؤول سابق في الامم المتحده
كنت معنا من
مومباسا قالت مصادر المانيه ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعتزم اطلاق بعثه عسكريه مدنيه
في غرب افريقيا واضافت المصادر ان البعثه
ستضم افرادا من الشرطه والعسكريين دون
تحديد عددهم وبحسب المصادر فان المهمه
تنبع من مخاوف الاتحاد الاوروبي من ان
الجماعات الجهاديه يمكن ان توسع نشاطاتها
في غرب افريقيا الى البلدان الساحليه
الجنوبيه قباله خليج غينيا وتشمل الاهداف
بحسب المصادر التدريبه على مكافحه الارهاب
والمساعده التقنيه وبناء الثقه في
القطاعات الامنيه
المحليه الوجود العسكري الغربي في منطقه
غرب افريقيا العناوين والاسباب والتحديات
هو ما سنناقشه بعد قليل في فقره في
[موسيقى]
المتابعه الى تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ومع مضي كيف في تجهيزاتها
لاستقبال مقاتلات اف 16 وتدريب طياريها
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديمير زيلينسكي يطالب
القياده العسكريه في بلاده بتعجيل انشاء
بنيه تحتيه لاستقبال المقاتلات الجديده
وفي ظل هذه الاستعدادات اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه استهداف مطارا بمقاطعه كيف
واستهداف محطه رادار لكشف الاهداف الجويه
وتوجيه الطائرات المقاتله واستهداف انظمه
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات بالقرب من
مدينه
رو كثفت روسيا هجماتها على البنيه التحتيه
العسكريه للقواعد الجويه
الاوكرانيه احدثها اعلان موسكو استهداف
مطار في مقاطعه كيف بسلاح عالي الدقه
وتاكيدها اصابه جميع الاهداف المحدده
وبحسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فان الضربه
شملت ايضا تدمير محطه رادار لكشف الاهداف
الجويه وتوجيه الطائرات المقاتله واستهداف
انظمه الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات بالقرب
من مدينه زابورجيا ويبدو واضحا ان الضربات
تستهدف ادارات ومواقع قواعد سلاح الجو في
اوكرانيا التي تنقسم الى ثلاث مناطق
رئيسيه مقر قياده سلاح الجو وتتبع ضمن
الدائره الاداريه المباشره له اربع مطارات
عسكريه قياده المنطقه الجنوبيه في سلاح
الجو وتتبع لها ثلاثه مطارات عسكريه خرج
احدها وهو مطار وقاعده بلبيك في
سيفاستوبول عن سيطره اوكرانيا بضم روسيا
شبه جزيره القرم قياده المنطقه الغربيه في
سلاح الجو الاوكراني ويتبع لها مطاران
عسكريان ومع تسارع الخطوات التي يمكن ان
تفضي لحصول اوكرانيا على مقاتلات اف س 16
بموافقه دول على تقديم طرازات غير حديثه
منها الى كيف وبدء تدريب طيارين اوكرانيين
تسارعت الضربات لكن الاستهداف الاحدث بحسب
خبراء لا يتعلق فقط باخراج مطارات عسكريه
من الخدمه بل بمحاوله تعطيل ما يمكن ان
يكون قواعد توجيه للطائرات المسيره التي
باتت السلاح الاوكرانيه الاكثر استخداما
في العمق الروسي ضربات تؤدي الى ايقاف
حركه مطارات العاصمه موسكو ولو انها لم
تصب هذه المنشات كما باتت تشكل تهديدا
لمواقع صناعيه روسيه كما يحدث في استهداف
كالوجا اكثر من مره وباضافة
ان هذه العناصر مجتمعه قد تشير لتبدل في
تكتيكات الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني الذي
يتعثر عند خطوط التماس بين الجيشين لكنه
يحقق نقاطا لصالح كيف في الاستهدافات غير
التقليديه وكانت الاداره العسكريه في كيف
اكدت ان انظمه الدفاع الجوي صدت هجوما
جويا روسيا على مشارف العاصمه فجر اليوم
بدورها اكدت قياده القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه ان دفاعاتها الجويه دمرت اربعه
صواريخ كروز في وسط وشمال اوكرانيا وقالت
ان الصواريخ اطلقت من خمس قاذفات
استراتيجيه من داخل الاجواء
الروسيه وتعليقا على الهجوم في كيف قالت
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في
الجيش الاوكراني نتاليا هوم نيوك ان هجوم
اليوم اتخذ شكلا معقدا من المنا را
لمحاوله خداع الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه
واستنزافها ينضموا الينا من بيروت العميد
الياس حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اهلا بك عميد حنا عميد حنا هل هنالك تكثيف
للضربات الروسيه للبنيه التحتيه الجويه
الاوكرانيه فيده هي منذ ايام سيرو فيكين
بدات ضرب
الاهداف او البنى التحتيه المدنيه
والعسكريه الشيء الجديد اليوم هو استهداف
القواعد الجويه في غرب اوكرانيا لسببين
اساسيين اولا دائما الطيران الاوكراني
يبدل مواقعه بصوره مستمره كي لا يكون هدف
سهل اثنين من هذه القواعد تنطلق الطائرات
الاوكرانيه من صنع سوفيتي والتي تستعمل
ستورم شادو لقصف الاهداف مثل الاهداف
القرم او حتى في العمق الروسي ثلاثه الهدف
هو منع ال القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه من
تحضير الارضيه او البنى التحتيه لاي شيء
مستقبلي بانتظار قدوم الاف 16 هذه هي
الثلاثه اسباب باختصار فدا طيب ما مدى
استعداد اوكرانيا اساسا لاستقبال هذه
الطائرات على ضوء ما قاله زيلنسكي ودعى
بتعجيل انشاء بنيه تحتيه لاستقبال
المقاتلات
الجديده ايه اظهرت القوات الاوكرانيه
القدره على الاستيعاب السريع والابتكار
وهي قادره على تحضير الارضيه ولن تكون
تحضير الارضيه فدا من صناعه اوكرانيه بحته
يجب ان ياتي خبراء اساسيين يحضرون لل
المدارج التي تحمل هذه الطائرات للذخيره
للصيانه معامل الصيانه مشاغل الصيانه وحتى
الرادارات والتكنولوجيا وكيف يمكن ضبطها
مع بعضها البعض لادخالها في المنظومه
العسكريه التي تستعملها اليوم اوكرانيا
الامر ليس بالامر السهل ولكن هذه احدى
الاوامر الاساسيه وقد بدا المشروع ونحن في
اول الطريق شكرا لك عميد الياس حناء
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من
لبنان قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
مقاتله روسيه من طراز سو 30 منعت طائره
استطلاع امريكيه من نوع رر من انتهاك
المجال الجوي الروسي فوق مياه البحر
الاسود ومن الاجواء في البحر الاسود الى
الاجواء السوريه حيث قال نائب رئيس المركز
العسكري الروسي في قاعده حميميم ان
الطائرات الامريكيه خلقت ظروفا خطيره في
المجال الجوي السوري واكد المسؤول الروسي
ان خروق طائرات التحالف في المجال الجوي
السوري لم يتم التنسيق فيها مع الجانب
الروسي هذا وتصاعدت في الاونه الاخيره
الاحتكاكات الجويه الروسيه الامريكيه في
اجواء سوريا ما طرح تساؤلات عن حدود
التصعيد جوا والقائم بين البلدين هناك
ياتي ذلك بينما تبادلت موسكو وواشنطن
الاتهامات بشان خروقات اتفاقيه منع
التصادم التي تحكم الانشطه الجويه بين
مختلف القوات الموجوده في
سوريا
الثال من يوليو تموز الماضي في سماء سوريا
تقترب مقاتله روسيه وفق الجيش الامريكي من
طائره امريكيه المسيره من نوع ام كيو ت
تضيقها وتطلق مشاعل مضيئه من نقطه تعترض
مسار المسيره مباشره ومن مسافه امتار
قليله لتصيب احداها مروحه الطائره المسيره
وتلحق بها اضرارا بالغه حادثه من بين
اخريات تكررت دفعت وزير الدفاع الامريكي
لويد اوستن لدعوه القياده الروسيه ل تكد
من انها تصدر توجيهات لقواتها لما سماه
الالتزام بقوانين السماء دعوه تعكس حجم
التوتر الذي اضحت الاجواء السوريه مسرحا
له فثلاث ايام بعد الحادث قال مركز
المصالحه الروسي في سوريا ان طائره مسيره
تابع للتحالف الدولي الذي تقوده الولايات
المتحده اقتربت بما ينذر بالخطر من طائره
عسكريه روسيه من طراز سوخوي 34 في يوم
واحد وفق المركز سجلت ثمان حالات انتهاك
لبروتوكولات تفادي التصادم لثلاث طائرات
مسيره امريكيه في منطقه التنف وبالمجمل في
حصيله شهر يوليو الماضي لوحده تحدث المركز
عن نحو 300 تجاوز امريكي لبروتوكولات منع
التصادم ونحو 23 مواجهه خطيره هذا العام
من طيران التحالف مع الطائره الروسيه في
سماء سوريا بالمقابل في السادس من يوليو
تموز الفائد افادت القوات الجويه
الامريكيه بانخراط طائره روسيه فيما سمته
سلوكا غير امن وغير احترافي اثناء
مشاركتها في مهمه ضد تنظيم الدوله في
الاجواء السوريه وتحدث مسؤولون امريكيون
عن وجود احتكاكات جويه روسيه امريكيه في
الاجواء السوريه في يوليو الماضي نحو ست
مرات خط عدم الاشتباك بين الجيشين في
سوريا لتجنب الاخطاء او المواجهات غير
المقصوده دفع البلدين للاعلان في تشرين
الاول اكتوبر عام
2015 عن اتفاقيه لمنع التصادم بين
الطائرات الروسيه والامريكيه في الاجواء
السوريه تتضمن قواعد وقيودا يجب على اطقم
الطيران اتباعها بالاضافه الى انشاء حلقه
اتصالات ارضيه بين الجانبين في حال تعطل
الاتصالات الجويه وان تحرص الطائرات في
الجانبين على الحفاظ على مسافه امنه تتهم
روسيا واشنطن بالقيام برحلات جويه غير
قانونيه في سوريا وتفعيل طيارها انظمه
الاسلحه عند الاقتراب من الطائرا الروسيه
بينما يتهم المسؤولون الامريكي الطيارين
الروس باستخدام اساليب غير مهنيه واستفزاز
طائرات التحالف الدولي خلال القيام
بعمليات ضد تنظيم
[موسيقى]
الدوله قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو ان حكومته ست ستجعل من
يمول الهجمات على اسرائيل يدفع ثمنا باهظا
وفق تعبيره وفي الجلسه الحكوميه وجه
نتنياهو رساله تهديد لنائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي لحركه حماس صالح
العاروري سمعت اقوال الغرور والتفاخر
للمسؤول في حركه حماس العاروري من مخبئه
في لبنان وهو يعرف جيدا لماذا هو واصدقائه
موجودون في المخابئ حماس وباقي اذرع ايران
يدركون كون جيدا اننا سنحارب بكل الوسائل
ضد محاولاتهم لانتاج ارهاب ضدنا في الضفه
الغربيه وغزه وفي كل موقع من يحاول المساس
بناء ومن يمول وينظم ويرسل الارهابيين ضد
اسرائيل سيدفع
الثمن من جانبها وصفت حركه حماس تهديدات
نتنياهو باغتيال العرور بالجوف وقالت
الحركه ان تهديدات الاحتلال لن ترهب الشعب
الفلسطيني محذره من المساس بقاده المقاومه
ونشرت وسائل اعلام فلسطينيه صوره ظهر فيها
العاروري بالزي العسكري وامامه قطعه سلاح
بعد ساعات قليله من تصريحات
نتنياهو ينضم الينا من عمان معين الطاهر
الكاتب والباحث الفلسطيني سيد معين خطاب
التصعيد والوعيد على الرغم من انه لم يؤدي
الى وقف عمليات المقاومه الا ان نتنياهو
مستمر فيه اي دوافع تقف وراء استمرار هذا
الخطاب
بتقديرك يعني اظن ان اللافت في هذا
الموضوع هو اجتماع ال الكابينت الحكوميه
الاسرائيليه المصغره والتي تضم بالعاده
رئيس الوزراء ووزير الدفاع ومسؤولي
الاجهزه الامنيه وبعض اعضاء الكابينت في
هذا الاجتماع تم اتخاذ قرار و ف فويض جلنت
وزير الدفاع ونتنياهو باتخاذ الاجراءات
التي يرونها ضروريه دون حاجه الى استشاره
الحكومه بما في ذلك حيث يعني كما تسرب بما
في ذلك تنفيذ سياسه اغتيالات سواء كان ذلك
في داخل الاراضي الفلسطينيه او خارجها اظن
ان الهدف الاول من هذا الاجتماع كان
محاوله من نتنياهو لتهدئه الجمهور
الصهيوني المتطرف لتهدئ
المستوطنين بعد عمليه حواره ولكن قد تكون
هنالك اهداف ابعد من ذلك عندما يتحدث
الاسرائيليون عن الاغتيال ليس بالضروره ان
يكون المستهدف بالاغتيال هو صالح العاروري
حتى لو مع اهميته بطبيعه الحال حتى لو تم
تركيز الاضواء الاعلاميه عليه قد يكون هذا
مجرد تمويع الهدف الذي سيكون بمتناول ال
الجيش الاسرائيلي هو الهدف الذي سيصد نه
لكن السؤال ما هي تبعات ذلك لاحظنا
ان السيد صالح العاروري قد قام
ب التهديد بان اي عمليه اغتيال كبيره
اي قد تتبعها حرب اطلق عليها يعني تعبير
حرب شامله او مواجهه كبيره انا يعني
المعلوم ان العروره في لبنان هل يمكن ان
تصل يد اسرائيل الى لبنان في هذا
التوقيت نعم هذا هذا ما اود قوله هل هذه
يعني يجب علينا ان نتساءل هل هذه
التهديدات
الاسرائيليه هي او تنفيذ لاحدى عمليات
الاغتيال هي محاوله من اسرائيل لتنفيذ
الاستراتيجيه التي اعلن عنها مؤخرا حول
رؤيه نتنياهو الامنيه بمعنى اخر انه تكون
عمليه الاغتيال بمثابه الشراره التي ستشعل
اشتباكا ستشعل حربا لكنني لا اعتقد انها
ستكون حربا شامله وانما ستكون مواجهه
قاسيه كبيره تمتد عبر الحدود ربما بال
ربما اكثر من ذلك تمتد ايضا الى قطاع غزه
و ربما تبدا من قطاع غزه وتنتقل الى الى
لبنان لونان وربما تكون هذه ايضا فرصه
للاسرائيليين لتوجيه ضربه خصوصا اذا رد
حزب الله والمقاومه في لبنان على عمليه
الاغتيال والضربات الاسرائيليه ربما هذه
تكون فرصه للحكومه الاسرائيليه لتوجيه
ضربه ما حتى الى ايران ولكن سياسه نتنياهو
علينا ان ندرك انه سيسعى الى وقف هذه
الحرب باسرع وقت ممكن كي لا تؤثر على
الجبهه الداخليه له بشكل كبير وسيحاول قدر
الكان المنطقه الحدوديه سيد معين في حال
تم توسيع هذه الحرب
لتشمل قطاع غزه وايضا لبنان ما الضمانه ان
لا ترد الساحات الاخرى خاصه ان اسرائيل
حذرت من ذلك اكثر من
مره نعم لا توجد ضمانه بطبيعه الحال على
الاطلاق لكن
انا يف
نتنياهو نع نع نعم انا اظن انه في لحظه ما
قد لا تكون الان ولكن في لحظه ما اسرائيل
ستقوم بتوجيه مثل هذه الضربه ويجب على ال
القوى الاخرى ان تستعد تماما وان تضع
سيناريوهاتها كيف يمكن ان تطيل هذه
المواجهه و ان تطيل هذه الحرب نقطه الضعف
في الوضع الاسرائيلي هو الجبهه الداخليه
اذا تمكنت الاطراف
من ايلام الجبهه الداخليه انا اعتقد هنا
انه قد يمكن تحقيق بعض الانجازات دون سنى
من الذي ستحمله الايام المقبله سيد معين
الطاهر الكاتب والباحث الفلسطيني كنت معنا
من
عمان
[موسيقى]
قالت الخارجيه الاسرائيليه ان لقاء جمع
وزير الخارجيه ايي كوهن بنظرته الليبيه
نجلاء المنقوش الاسبوع الماضي في العاصمه
الايطاليه روما وذكر بيان للخارجيه
الاسرائيليه ان اللقاء كان لبحث امكانيه
التعاون واقامه علاقات متبادله وكيفيه
الحفاظ على التراث اليهودي في ليبيا
وتعقيبا على البيان قال وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي ان اللقاء يعد خطوه اولى في
العلاقات بين اسرائيل وليبيا وفي ردود
الفعل الليبيه طالبت كتله التوافق في
المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا باقاله
وزيره الخارجيه نجلاء المنقوش من منصبها
بعد لقائها بنظيرها الاسرائيلي كما طالبت
الكتله باستقاله جماعيه للحكومه والمجلس
الرئاسي في حال وجد تنسيق مسبق بشان
اللقاء بينما استنكر حزب العداله بناء
اللقاء وطالب رئيس الحكومه باقاله وزيره
الخارجيه من
منصبها نقل مراسل الجزيره في ليبيا عن
المتحدثه باسم المجلس الرئاسي نجوى وهيبه
ان المجلس طالب حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
بموافاته بشان اجتماع وزيره الخارجيه
نجلاء المنقوش مع وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي في ايطاليا وطالب المجلس
باتخاذ اجراءات رادعه وفقا للقوانين
والتشريعات نافذه بهذا الخصوص واعتبر
المجلس في مراسلته للحكومه ان ما ورد في
وسائل الاعلام بهذا الشان لا يعبر عن
السياسه الخارجيه للدوله ويخرق القوانين
الليبيه التي تجرم التطبيع مع الكيان
الصهيوني واكد المجلس الرئاسي ان مخرجات
ملتقى الحوار السياسي الليبي في جنيف
اوكلت الى المجلس متابعه ملف السياسه
الخارجيه والاشراف
عليه
في باكستان وصفت الهيئه الوطنيه لاداره
الكوارث مستوى المياه المتدفقه في نهر
ستوج بالخطير وفي تصريح للجزيره انتقد
مسؤول في اداره الري باقليم البنجاب الهند
بسبب استمرارها في تصريف المياه عبر
الانهر المشتركه بين البلدين ويواجه
المتضررون من الفيضان في البنجاب اوضاعا
صعبه لا سما بعد خسارتهم لمنازلهم وحقولهم
زراعيه مع اتساع رقعه المناطق المتضرره من
فيضان اقليم البنجابي الباكستاني تضيق
الخيارات امام
المتضررين بوسائل بسيطه ينقل هؤلاء ما
تيسر من متاعي بيوت غمرتها
المياه فيما اختار نور واسرته استغلال
بقعه جافه في بيتهم المحاط بالفيضان
للبقاء فيها مع
مواشيهم البيت مرتفع بعض الشيء عما حوله
ومع ذلك لم يتبقى لنا منه الا هذه البقعه
الجافه نشعر بالقلق كثيرا خلال الليل بسبب
وجود افع سامه وحشرات ونخشى مرض اطفالنا
لا يوجد بالقرب منا اي مركز
صحي جدران البيت هي اول ما تهدم ثم بدات
المياه تتسرب الى الداخل حاولت قدر
المستطاع الاعتناء باحفاد اخاف عليهم
كثيرا تقول باكستان ان الهند صرفت خلال
شهر واحد المياه عبر نهري ستلج وناب
المشتركين دفع ذلك السلطات الى تسريع
وتيره اعمال صيانه شبكات الري للتعامل مع
مياه فيضانات تغمر عده محافظات باقليم
البنجاب متاخمه للحدود مع الهند ان جوانب
ت الهند هي من تصرف المياه وبشكل متكرر
باتجاه باكستان وبكميات قياسيه لم تسجل
منذ 35 عاما وما لم تتوقف الهند عن ذلك
فلن يخف الضغط عن انهارنا وقنواتها
المائيه بالرغم من كثره المياه هنا فان ما
يصلح للاستخدام منها قليل وكل ما يتوفر
ياتي من ابار محفوره تجاوز عمقها 70
مترا
فيضانات اقليم البنجاب ملمح اخر من ملامح
التوتر بين الهندي وباكستان لا يلغي ذلك
حقيقه ان باكستان واحده من اكثر البلدان
تعرضا للتغيرات المناخيه
وتاثر بالفيضانات المدمره عبد الرحمن مطار
الجزيره اقليم
البنجاب
في توقيت غير طبيعي يتم الكشف عن نيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي اطلاق عمليه عسكريه
مدنيه جديده في القاره الافريقيه وتحديدا
في غرب القاره الذي يشهد
احتداماً مبدا لا علاقه للعمليه بما شهدته
هذه البلدان الثلاثه وانما هو عمل سيكون
موجها لعمليات مكافحه الارهاب العمليه
يفترض ان تنطلق في الخريف
وسيتمكّن حديث عنها هذه الايام حيث توجد
فيها اربع قواعد امريكيه وفرنسيه وايطاليه
والمانيه بقيه الدول كما ترون على هذه
الخريطه اما الاتحاد الاوروبي فكانت قوته
المشتركه موجوده في مالي بشكل اساسي وبعد
انسحاب القوات الفرنسيه من هناك لم يتبقى
سوى بعثه تدريب محدوده للاتحاد في مجال
دعم الامن تسمى يوكاب
ابرز العمليات العسكريه في السنوات
القليله الماضيه في افريقيا غالبيتها
فرنسيه بدعم دول اوروبيه منها عمليه
سيرفال ففي يناير كانون الثاني
2013 اطلقت فرنسا عمليه سيرفال بهدف وقف
تقدم جماعات مسلحه نحو جنوب مالي كما نشرت
فرنسا عام
2013 قرابه 5000 جندي في مالي في محاوله
لمنع جماعات متطرفه من اقامه موطئ قدم لها
لتطلق في صيف
2014 عمليه برخان وقد فشلت القوات
الفرنسيه في وضع حد للهجمات رغم مطالبتها
بدعم اوروبي ومع تصاعد التوتر مع باماكو
انهت فرنسا وجودها في مالي في اب اغسطس
عام
20122 حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
رولاند فرودن شتاين نائب رئيس مؤسسه جلوب
سك للدراسات والابحاث
المتخصصه للامن الدولي اهلا بك سيد رولند
سيد
رولند العنوان العريض لهذه المهمه المدنيه
العسكريه هو مكافحه الارهاب ولكن هل هذه
هي الدوافع
الحقيقيه
نعم نعم هذا هو الهدف الاساسي بالتاكيد
هنالك مصالح اكبر قد يكون الاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده وكل
الديمقراطيات في العالم لديها موجوده
وايضا هنالك مساله الهجره وهنالك الموارد
الطبيعيه ايضا لكن الاهم والاول هو مساله
الديمقراطيه هي التي على المحاك و هذا ما
يريد الاتحاد الاوروبي ان يحميه يعني
غالبيه هذه الدول تحد من الجنوب النيجر
وبوركينا فاسو هل هل هل بالتالي الهدف هو
فقط
مكافحه الارهاب ولماذا اذا كان مكافحه
الارهاب هو الهدف الاساسي هذه الدول التي
ستنتشر فيها هذه المهمه لا تعاني فعليا من
انتشار ارهاب بشكل
واسع
ليس بعد لكن قد يحصل هذا الامر مستقبلا
ونحن جميعا نعرف ان الفساد والقمع قمع
الحركات
الديمقراطيه هما
مصدران يتغذى عليهما الارهاب بالتالي
ديمقراطيات المنطقه تحتاج الى نوع من
الحمايه والمساعده من الخارج طيب 100 عنصر
حسب ما يبدو بان هذه المهمه تتالف من 100
عنصر كيف يمكن ان يخدم كل هذه العناوين
الكبيره ما الذي ستغيره هذه المهمه على
الارض بالتاكيد فان اي تدخل عسكري واسع هو
ليس مطروحا الان بالتالي الاتحاد الاوروبي
عليه ان يقوم بما هو ممكن وما هو مقبول من
قبل الدول المستقبله سيد رولند هنالك من
يرى بان الاتحاد الاوروبي انما يستدرك
خطوره النفوذ الروسي والصيني المتصاعد في
هذه المنطقه وبالتالي يحاول ان يوازن ذلك
هل توافق على
هذه
الاستنتاجات
نحن لم نولد يوم امس نحن لا لسنا سذج
بمعنى ان الدعم الذي تقدمه روسيا والصين
لهذه للانظمه المستبده مثلا المجلس
العسكري في الموجود في النيجر حاليا هو
شيء تم تحديده على انه خطر منذ وقت طويل
بالتالي ليس هنالك اي حلول سريعه وسهله
لهذا الوضع نحن نختار بين الخيارات السيئه
والخيارات الاسوا واعتقد حاليا ان الاقل
سوءا والخيار الاقل سوءا الان للاتحاد
الاوروبي هو ان يستخدم ربما ادوات مدنيه
واسعه وادوات اقتصاديه من اجل مقاومه
النفوذ الصيني والنفوذ الروسي وان تقوم
يقوم الاتحاد الاوروبي بدعم الحكومات
الديمقراطيه في المنطقه والمجتمع المدني
شكرا لك سيد رونالد فرود شين نائب رئيس
مؤسسه جلوب سك للدراسات والابحاث
المتخصصه في الامن
الدولي نهايه الحصاد تصبحون على
[موسيقى]
خير
ه